hey how's Cobras alright so today we're
going to discover what anime looks like
in real life I don't remember where this
anime was called but let's try and and
see what they look like in real life
let's start with suzumiya haruhi i think
that how do you yeah all right first of
all the faith's needs to be about 500%
wider so let's do that
that looks great
second of all the nose can't have a nose
if you're an emu then your nose needs to
be disapproved
[Music]
looks [ __ ] amazing the mouth needs to
be kinda like kinda like a cow tongue
now the lips needs to be non-existent so
let's make sure they're gone
I really should reconsider YouTube and
become a bi sixer in Chennai eyebrows
need to be sharp as needles and then
finally the eyes need to be jive [ __ ]
Danny you're gonna be an emu as [ __ ]
[Music]
so much effort there we have it how do
we use this in the air this 10 EMU ever
yep
next one laughing god sorry I got a
little we're on a route oh let's find a
Japanese model that looks similar there
it is
first off let's start with the nose go
away nose
[Music]
you're practically only allowed to keep
your nostrils whatever makes you breathe
you can keep but not the actual shape
second of all the shape of the face
needs to be better it's way better
[Music]
a right next step the beautiful eyes it
looks like we're gonna have to give this
boy an eye transplant because he doesn't
have blue eyes so you can't have it all
that looks great
now for some small detail work of course
Naruto
senpai Naruto I was gonna I was gonna
search thick Japanese eyebrows and then
thick Japanese noodles came up and I
feel like in Naruto's case this might
even be better for eyebrows see we got
the same result from noodles who would
have thought now for the next step we
need to make his hair yellow and make it
into Lisa Simpsons hair cut
[Music]
we got a bullet bleach that hair first
that's right baby
excellent results such good results
Naruto will thank you your your hair
roots
Naruto's try to make a joker right sorry
this has to be the greatest Photoshop of
all time why not get this headband
Naruto it looks so good and you're
practically a Naruto Wow such great
results it's almost like I can't tell
them apart oh I forgot the whiskers
there we go Naruto complete Wow can we
do a real-life attack up tight and
that'd be pretty cool okay how about I
turn myself into a Titan yes great idea
this is what we want to achieve perfect
dental teeth let's let's see if we kids
yes we can do it after learning my
fingers I feel Airy matters
[Music]
beautiful
this looks so [ __ ] up unintentionally
[ __ ] up
[Music]
I was really annoyed by the fact that I
don't have my mic gum but I do have it
here so we're gonna transplant
oh god that's that's a bigger gum than I
ever wanted to see oh my god okay so
yeah let's put that in there and see
what happens
[Music]
beautiful and magical mystical and
beautiful I said beautiful to me
[Music]
[Applause]
yay nightmares you're welcome attack on
the pills in real life portal let's see
what you ever think you're a weeaboo
[ __ ] me hard
don't eat my mother now you can get me
out more violently
alright bris that's all the photoshop so
we're gonna do today what animates do
you want to see in the next episode
leave a like if you want more and I will
see you bros in the next one thanks for
watching here comes the growth phase
stay awesome pretty how the hell I'm
gonna make it that happy yeah that looks
that looks great thank you